you're going to do an exercise called if
I were Prime Minister via can you stop
okay everyone is welcome
regardless of nationality and if I was
Prime Minister that's what I'd stand for
[Music]
we have breaking news a large explosion
has gone off in the center of the city
we will suspend activities until we get
some more information
okay I'm a muscle-up IDI you heard about
the bomb in the city yes I've been sent
to secure the island
actually can I see your ID yeah sure was
that something with body roll and we
need to find out what it's the only way
we will get through this I want to make
you see what is it done I just want to
beat him maybe this is your chance the
person there arrested he asked for me
why there are witnesses I need to
cross-examine Norway isn't on trial you
are are you sure about that
I just don't want every week not in
front of him
you can be weak and still strong you
know about right I still have hope
dreams
in France
and it's used to live
you